the Clone Wars era Ahsoka Tano has
finally made a live-action debut and you
might have noticed issues played by a
familiar face so who is Ariana
Greenblatt the actor who played her
like many young actors before her Ariana
greenblatt's got to start working on the
small screen and before long she became
one of the faces of the Disney Channel
after playing a few minor roles in
Disney shows greenblatt's Big Break came
courtesy of the sitcom stuck in the
middle which ran for three seasons
between 2016 and 2018 Stuck in the
Middle sees Greenblatt played Daphne
Diaz a youngest sibling in a family with
six children the character is known for
vandalizing her dolls a unique sense of
style and a precocious nature speaking
to j14 greenplus said that she imagines
Daphne will grow up to start her own
business and that it will probably
involve dolls spedoff hasn't happened
yet but who knows while stuck in the
middle boasts an All-Star cast including
a young Jenna Ortega greenblatt's unique
character and impressive performance
helped her to stand out from the pack it
seems she was always destined for big
things however and it didn't take long
for the actress to get offered movie
roles after the Disney sitcom ended
shortly after catching a big break on
the small screen Ariana greenblatts
landed her first feature film role
starring in the 2017 comedy a bad Moms
Christmas the sea quarter 2016's bad
moms follows a group of overburdened
mothers who are forced to contend with
their own parents during the holiday
season hijinks and Sue of course in the
movie Greenblatt plays Lori hognes the
daughter of Jay Hernandez and Mila
Kunis's characters in one of the film's
funniest scenes Lori confronts her
mother about the strange noises and foul
language that she hears coming out of
her parents bedroom which results in an
awkward exchange between the pair in an
interview with bionic Buzz greenblad
said that she loved working with her
co-stars adding that collaborating with
them was a highlight of the entire shoot
virtual a bad Moms Christmas gave her
the chance to show off her comedic chops
Greenblatt was about to make a big leap
into a very different franchise
what did it cost
everything
Ariana greenblood southing is a young
Jedi Ahsoka Tano isn't the first time
that she's played a younger version of a
formidable hero in a hugely popular
franchise prior to starring on Ahsoka
she portrayed young Gamora in Avengers
Infinity War featuring in a pair of
scenes alongside Josh Brolin's Thanos
greenblatt's big moments occurs and
Thanos and his forces invade the younger
Morris home planet despite her best
efforts to fight off some of the
villains minions she can't resist his
offer of Helm thus begins a
dysfunctional father-daughter
relationship that ultimately ends in
tragedy most actors would do anything to
be part of the Star Wars and Marvel
franchises and it seems like greenblatts
can now take both offer less despite the
fact her career is just getting started
based on Catherine Alice Applegate's
novel of the same name the one and only
Ivan tells the story of a gorilla who
teams up with an elephant to escape from
captivity Ariana Greenblatt plays Julia
an artistically driven child Who
develops a bond with the ape through
their shared sense of loneliness this
role struck a core with the young
actress at the time during a
conversation with the movie times green
Platt explained that she was already a
fan of the book prior to Landing the
part in the same interview Greenblatt
also opened up about What attracted her
to the role of Julia in the first place
according to the actress she identified
with the character due to their mutual
love of animals and drawing making it
quite the fun role to play
in 2020 Ariana Greenblatt landed a
supporting role in Netflix's
post-apocalyptic creature flick love and
monsters this story centers around Joel
Dawson and his loyal canine friend as
they embark on an adventure to reunite
with Joel's high school sweetheart this
adventure brings him into contact with a
cast of fascinating characters including
greenblatt's survivalist expert minnow
one of the film's standout characters
minova companies Michael rooker's
character Clyde in his quest to find a
safe haven in the harsh wastelands
they're both portrayed as experts at
surviving in the ravaged new world and
worked together to overcome the
Monstrous threats that dwell there
what's she so scared for the older
snares are nice there can be nice ones
this is arguably one of greenblot's most
mature roles to date a third character
is one who has experienced some tough
times during her short life she also
capably holds her own alongside veteran
actor Rooker making their characters
feel more like equals than an adult
child pairing
awake tells the story of a catastrophic
events that simultaneously takes away
humankind's ability to fall asleep and
shuts off all the world's Electronics
with the world trapped in a state of
insomnia-induced Hysteria and no means
to recharge people gradually become more
and more unhinged forcing scientists to
come up with a solution Before Time Runs
Out Ariana Greenblatt plays Matilda in
awake a child who as one of the few who
is able to sleep might hold the key to
humankind's Salvation however this puts
her in considerable danger as some
people want to sacrifice her meanwhile
Matilda's mother wants to keep her alive
at all costs and comes up with an
alternative solution to the problem
while awaker didn't exactly receive
heaps of critical Acclaim greenblad's
performance certainly caused Hollywood's
attention as she moved on to a number of
other noteworthy projects afterward and
the actress credits this one as one of
her favorite roles telling him published
Zine that it allowed her to Showcase
more acting range than ever before at
the time she said this role really
pushed me and shows an emotional range
and his very action-packed which is
something I've never done before it was
so much fun
an adaptation of lim Manuel Miranda's
first set stage musical in the Heights
hit theaters in 2021 the film follows
uznavi a New York City Bodega owner who
dreams about living a better life he
wants to go back to his native Dominican
Republic so he saves up his pennies in
the hope of realizing that ambition
greenblad plays a younger version of
Nina a lead character who returns home
from college to spend the summer in the
neighborhood the musical genre turned
out to be a good fit for Greenblatt
while she doesn't have one of the main
roles in the Heights her history as a
dancer makes her perfect for roles of
this elk during a conversation with Elle
she said that she's been dancing for
most of her life so it wouldn't be
surprising if she tackles more roles in
the genre down the line in the meantime
fans who want to check out greenblatt's
skills can also revisit her tenure on
Dancing With the Stars where she
finished as a fourth place runner-up
Ariana Grande glasses apparently
developed something of a taste for
post-apocalyptic movies but while most
of them have been sci-fi stories set in
the future one of her most recent roles
has set 65 billion years in the past in
65 the actress plays KOA a survivor of a
catastrophic event who must team up with
Adam driver's Mills to survive a land of
dinosaurs hear an adventure that's
reminiscent of The Last of Us with
elements of Jurassic Park and a quiet
place thrown in for good measure some
critics lambasted 65 as a dino boar that
failed to live up to its intriguing
premise but Greenblatt were to well with
the material and further prove that
she's a rising star in the world of
sci-fi and horror notably this was
arguably her biggest role to date as it
placed her front and center as a
co-leading of big budget Blockbuster
65 might not go down in history as one
of 2023's most acclaimed movies but
Barbies arguably a generation defining
Blockbuster in addition to being one of
this year's most successful movies both
commercially and critically Greta
gerwick's hair proved that auto Visions
can appeal to mainstream audiences
Ariana Greenblatt plays a standout part
in the movie as Sasha and angsty gen Z
teen who lost interest in playing with
dolls a long time ago Sasha is one of
the main human characters in Barbie the
titular doll comes to the human world to
find Sasha's mother Gloria and a
scrunzel Mattel employee who's trying to
find her purpose in life initially
though Barbie thinks she's going to help
the teen Sasha and Gloria don't always
see eye to eye and their relationship is
at the heart of some of the film's
funniest and most dramatic scenes are
you really gonna let Barbie take you and
your tween daughter to an imaginary land
yes and you want to know why because I
never get to do anything for greenblad's
portraying the Gen Zetta was an
opportunity for her to play an authentic
teenage girl on the screen she told The
Hollywood Reporter I tried to at least
make Sasha as relatable as possible I
wanted to represent teenage girls
appropriately no one understands a
teenage girl unless you were one once in
your life
Ariana greenblatt's next feature film
role will see her return to Familia
ground as she's set to play Tiny Tina in
Eli waff's upcoming Borderlands
adaptation the Sci-Fi actionable
Chronicle The Adventures of a band of
Misfits as they travel across an alien
infested planet to find the daughter of
one of the most important people in the
universe in addition to aliens the
heroes will also have to contend with
Bandits Savages and other villainous
deviants who populate the planet it
remains to be seen how each character
will be portrayed in the movie but Tina
greenblatt's character has been
described as feral indeed this might be
her most unhinged role to date and is
bound to Showcase a whole new cider for
acting sensibilities Furthermore with
Wrath of the helm coupled with the
source material that inspired the movie
this is bound to be a violent affair
with plenty of dark humor thrown into
the mix for Borderlands Greenblatt will
be joined by an All-Star cast that
includes Kate Blanchard Jack Black Jamie
Lee Curtis Kevin Hart and many more
unfortunately Borderlands won't be
released until next August following
Ahsoka though it's only a matter of time
until Ariana Greenblatt appears an even
more hypo profile projects